Fox News contributor Charlie hurt former
White House physician Texas Congressman
Ronnie Jackson Ronnie I've been asking
you regularly about his cognitive state
to me
um I think it's getting worse and I
think it's more obvious and I don't
think they're going to be so it's not
going to be so easy this time to hide
them in the basement bunker your
thoughts
well they better start hiding him away
quick chunk because you're right it's
getting worse by the day and you know I
don't even know what else to say about
this I just thought it it would be
comical if it weren't so disastrous for
our country right now you saw when he
was with uh fetterman this weekend the
two of them were sitting there bantering
back and forth he can't stand understand
either one of them I think that you know
I think uh Biden is kind of the
fetterman whisperer now I mean he may be
the only one that can understand what
betterment's saying and vice versa it's
almost like they've created their new
little language now that they must have
built up somewhere along the way maybe
when they were tucked away in the
respective races in the in their
basement but they've got to do something
with this guy because I mean he Sean I
know 10 year olds I know a bunch of 10
year olds that could do a better job and
it's far more confidence in in what's
going on in our country than these guys
can't it's this is just uh I don't even
I'm at a loss for what to say about this
anymore I mean everyone knows what's
going on I mean you don't have to be a
physician to seek the disaster that were
that that's looking us right in the face
every day and I it's just we we've got
to fix it I mean you're right I mean I I
just do not see how they can keep him as
their nominee this is a long ways out
and it's it's going off the rails well I
mean historically people that have
cognitive decline like this it is
degenerative and it gets worse over time
um just a fact uh I'm speaking as a
non-doctor uh Mike Huckabee God saved
the queen man now 71 percent of
Americans think that this man is not
aware enough cognitively strong enough
to be president and half a Democrats
don't think he's strong enough to be
president my question is now I hear
behind the scenes that prominent
Democrats the chatter is building but
you're not hearing it so much across the
country why
well you said half the Democrats don't
think he's competent I want to know who
the heck of the half that think he is
those are the people I'd really like to
interview and say what does he say that
gives you such confidence when I was
watching fetterman and Biden together I
honestly thought I was watching a rerun
of some old Laurel and Hardy uh
comedy routines it was just sad my
two-year-old grandson makes more sense
than either one of them and he's two
years old but if it's about reading a
prompter or making a speech I honestly
think I could put the kid at the podium
and more people would understand what he
was saying this was embarrassing and
this whole thing of God saved the queen
maybe he's talking about the rock band
Queen and he's hoping that somehow even
without Freddie Mercury they'll still be
able to tour and and fill the stadiums
and Arenas around the world
you know and Charlie hurt I mean is is
this a back door is Miranda Devine
suggested in a well-written piece in the
New York Post today about you know for
Kamala Harris you know that that most
people are thinking that she would Jump
Right In okay but this is a woman who
herself has issues in terms of giving a
speech you know she talks about the
significance of the passage of time the
significance of the passage of time so
when you think about it there is great
significance in the passenger time never
mind it's time for us to be doing what
we've been doing and that time is every
day to do what we do I mean you know the
one that loves Venn diagrams or whatever
I mean is is she the answer for them
because I don't think so
you're going to get hired to be a
speechwriter you're going to get hired
to be a speechwriter for her
um no I think that that's one of the
real big problems for them is you know
what do you do with her uh you know it'd
be so much easier if they could just
sort of take Joe Biden out with the
garbage and replace him uh and have a
backup who was competent but I think
quite frankly uh uh Kamala Harris would
probably do even worse in a general or
even a primary fight uh and and of
course this is why I think Democrats are
so terrified of the rise of RFK uh who's
thrown his hat in the ring and then
instantly winds up with double a double
digit 20 percent of the vote among
Democrats and probably would pick up a
lot of Independence and and moderates as
well if it were if he were to run say a
third party campaign or something like
that but I think without a doubt um you
know more of these polls come out out
that show Trump uh soundly beating Joe
Biden the Democrats who are very very
you know they're very good at
controlling their party and at some
point they're all going to have to get
together the party leaders and make a
decision about what they want to do and
if they do make a decision I don't think
that Joe Biden or Kamala Harris or RFK
is going to be to their liking
all right so Ronnie Jackson let's look
at RFK for example he's now steadily at
21 in the in the polls against Biden and
Biden's in the 30s uh Marianne
Williamson's pulling 10 I I say that's
pretty respectable on her part
um here's RFK it takes a very different
position of us than his party on
immigration on biological Men playing
women's sports and on vaccines and and
covet in particular uh that has gotten a
lot of attention and but he does seem
out of touch with the base of the
democratic party but if you're looking
for an alternative to Biden he's
probably your best option now
he is right now but I think Sean at some
point there's going to be somebody from
the progressive Wayne that's going to
jump in and be the darling of the left
and they're just going to take off
because I think the Democrats right now
are just anybody but Biden and well you
know you know they they're opposed to
Trump obviously and at all cost and this
is just another example of like you know
uh what you're going to get you know
what you're going to let the country
devolve into just because you don't like
President Trump's style even though his
leadership was some of the best we've
ever had but you know I think that
anybody who gets in this race is going
to do extremely well on the left right
now because they are just I I hear them
talking behind the scenes and they don't
know what to do they're they're at a
loss most of them and this is a cover-up
I've said this before the White House
and the West Wing is covering this up as
doctors covering this up and eventually
they're going to call these people out
and say you need to get out and tell us
what's going on and I think uh you know
when when that happens it's going to be
obvious that he can't he can't serve
anymore
okay so a lot of there's been a lot of
speculation since my interview with
Gavin Newsom Governor Huckabee
um now I've known him for a long time
I'm the one that invited him personally
to come on the program uh to his credit
he came on I thought he dodged a lot of
important questions one question he
would not answer and that was you know
how many times his phone gets pinged
today by democrats begging him to run
another one is you know he kind of
pulled back on the issue of would you
under any circumstances challenge Biden
he tried to say no he defended Biden as
cognitively alert I think he's too smart
to really believe that and I I don't
think he was lying I think he was trying
to be a good Democrat that was my take
Mike Huckabee I think he gets a lot of
credit for coming on your show I mean a
lot of Democrats won't do that they
won't sit down with you and that was to
his credit but truthfully what he deep
down knows that Joe Biden is like a pack
of bottle rockets that have been soaked
in water all night they're never going
to ignite and he has to know that the
worst thing for the Democrat Party is
for Joe Biden to be the nominee why are
you laughing so hard Charlie hurt
um look today because even if it takes
it takes Mike Huckabee to to invoke a
fireworks uh analogy and it's a perfect
one well he's from Arkansas I mean
fireworks illegal down there unlike most
you know you know States like liberal
states like New York and California but
go ahead
right right no it's uh no it's a person
I want your take on him was this an
accident he decided to accept my
invitation or is
oh no I and and you know I agree with
you the the the my favorite part of that
your entire interview was when he
started waffling when you asked him how
often does he get uh get does his phone
ring with Democrats he ended that
exchange with he was not about to answer
that he ended it with I'm not going to
answer that question actually flat out
said it right and I give credit for
somebody to answer that that way
um but you know but but what's so great
about it is it captures how desperate I
think Democrats are to find anybody who
can string a sentence together to
challenge Biden and he didn't want to
admit that that he gets a lot of those
calls all right I'll ask all three of
you exit question and that is ultimately
will there be any prominent Democrat
that challenges Joe and do you think Joe
will be the nominee in 2024 Ronnie
Jackson you go first
somebody's going to challenge him he's
not going to be the nominee he can't
make it that far it's too far out
Governor Mike Huckabee
I think somebody will challenge him and
it very well could be Gavin Newsom uh
Joe Biden won't be the nominee one way
or the other he'll be either defeated or
somebody will convince him it's time for
him to step aside go to Delaware Drive
the Corvette and go through all those
boxes of classified materials that he
kept Charlie hurt
I you know I agree completely I think
that in the end he'll be taken out by
party leadership
okay now exit question Governor Huckabee
said it would likely be Newsome Ronnie
and Charlie I want to know who you think
it would be Ronnie first
I think it's going to be Newsome I mean
he's the one that's uh you know that's
that's pushing the hardest right now and
he's coming from a big state like
California uh you know the progressive
left loves him so I think it'll be
Newsome despite the fact that his own
State's an absolute disaster
Charlie last word
you know I can see Democrats going with
that as the consensus but the real uh
the real the the real Barbarian at the
gate would be RFK Jr I would love to see
what he would do to his party
and it'll be interesting to see how many
Democrats push Kamala Harris uh to be
the the one to replace him uh all three
of you are right it will not be Joe
Biden appreciate you being with us
coming up next hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else